oh wait this is a total detour but have
you got have you guys ever spent way too
much money on clothes and then been like
oh my god i did it i did the thing where
i bought in like thousands of dollars
where you're like where it's like wait
this is just basically i just blew all
this money on a suit like a designer
suit an amazing designer suit and i was
just like oh no
it just looks like a suit actually yeah
you know like have you guys ever done
that yeah but maybe it's worth it maybe
the lesson is like no people will know
that's a designer suit it's better did
they did you wear it i haven't worn it
in public yet no
but i wore it into a bat i took a bath
with it on
that's probably why you're feeling weird
yeah and then i felt weird about it i
was like i feel like i wasted my money
you know so i went into the hot tub to
like kind of feel just get my mind off
things yeah the swimsuit i just needed
to relax yeah yeah
it was a swimsuit
that's so bad
thank you
so much nice
would you buy for a wedding i bought i
bought one for a wedding and then i was
like you know what i don't like this one
that much i bought another designer suit
and then i was like i have spent many
thousands of dollars on
and they're sitting in my closet
you know like months and months of
money that could have been used for
anything else yeah no i mean i i did
that recently with a camera
i keep doing that yeah i keep buying
nice what kind of a picture camera or a
video camera yo fan
do you mind alexa no no i i [ __ ] i'm
there i'm right there wait what did you
buy i bought a c300 mark 3.
[Music]
oh those are amazing yeah audience yeah
it's a great doc camera but i'm like
yeah they shot blue as the warmest color
on those i think do you ever see that
movie no no no lesbians yeah really good
lesbian movie i'll go check that out
yeah that's on munch music right
yeah much music launched that in 2012
yeah
you bought a c300 yeah yeah i just
bought two black magic 6ks do you know
this camera yes let's go i don't use
them ever
because everything is just on your phone
yeah
i used to shoot sketches that looked
really good and now it's just like who
cares like just put a snapchat filter on
is that where you get the filters
snapchat a lot of them yeah snapchat and
instagram yeah and filterface.com no i'm
just kidding
there's no it's so funny if you've ever
like
brian j alfred yeah
yeah sign up with my promo code yeah it
is funny if you ever go to like an
off-brand filter site where it's like
funny face filters they're just horrible
yeah
you gotta you gotta go to the big boys
yeah snapchat yeah yeah that's where tj
mac is snapchat yeah and his wife too
it's so funny that you can buy like a
camera worth thousands of dollars
and yet like a snapchat filter and an
accent and improving boom that's what
the people are like
yeah i think it's just that nobody it's
like more but it's also that phones do
look so good now so i'm still like i
still have a cinematic eye so i'm like
but they're not all the way there the
background is blurry the color gradient
you know you probably but it's like
everybody else is like shut up like just
film it on your phone yeah and i've seen
so many funny even on tik tok funny
actual sketches that aren't just
somebody speaking a camera it's like
people doing like sketches like i like
have done before
just filming on your phone and i just
it's it's just time i think i just got
to sell them do you want to buy my
blackmagic six case yeah got a couple of
them i can offload real quick
well i'm trying to
are you using it for your youtube videos
i've used it for a couple things but i
think i'm gonna use it as to force
myself to make some more artistic stuff
only fantastic yeah only fan stuff yeah
yeah
yeah me farting on cakes and
putting my own foot in my mouth watching
that like
how did he film this
yeah beautiful yeah the colors are
really nice yeah the background is very
yeah that's when people really
appreciate cinematography now it's porn
yeah
it's the only it's the last bastard yeah
damn i think about the
the first cinematic porn i saw remember
ex-art yeah oh yeah do you ever barely
bear i mean that might be straight more
stronger i was gonna say did they make
any oh yeah i feel like they did i feel
like they would have had to like there's
no reason the government would have made
them yeah
make the gay form yeah we must make
everyone gay
make it you make them like it exactly it
look good too i remember yeah the first
x art i saw was like it was a weird like
rejection at first i'm like i don't it's
too pretty yeah like don't yeah you're
like
your body's trying to reject it no
i will not like it
i will not masturbate here or in a car
about there or very far yeah
yeah i will not masturbate to 4k or 6.
yeah
i will not masturbate on a big screen
like this
you got to put that in print
damn
you